Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Senolaydin.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Systemästhetik
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstehender?
Ja.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder etwas fragen möchten,
bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid.
Nun frage ich ganz kurz zu Ihrer Person,
dann höre ich Ihren Beschwerden zu.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Susanne Müller.
Susanne Müller.
Frau Müller, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname
langsam bestabilen?
Ja, Susanne schreibt sich S-U-S-A-N-N-E.
Susanne.
Okay.
Und von mir?
Großem, Ue, L-L-E-R.
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
50 Jahre.
50 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 11. Juni 1971.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m. Und wie schwer sind Sie? 63 kg.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie, Frau Müller? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen begann das. Ich habe ein Druckgefühl im Bauch.
Anfangs wie ein Druck und jetzt habe ich Schmerzen im Bauch.
Das tut mir sehr weh und deswegen komme ich zu Ihnen.
Wo gehen Sie nicht schnell zu?
Angefangen hat das mehr im mittleren Bauch um den Bauchnabel herum.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen mehr links unten im Bauch.
Links unten?
Ich trage nicht mehr auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leiteres Schmerz entspricht.
Das wechselt etwas, weil der Schmerz manchmal wie eine Welle ist.
Ich würde sagen zwischen 6 und 8.
Sind die Schmerzen krampfartig?
Ja, ein bisschen krampf, aber auch dann so, es kommt und geht wie eine Welle.
Haben Sie schon früher in dir beschwerden?
Vielleicht mal so vor einem halben Jahr, da hatte ich auch schon mal so ähnliche Beschwerden,
aber nicht so stark.
Das dauerte so 3-4 Tage und dann war das wieder besser, aber nicht so stark wie heute.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ist Ihnen oder war Ihnen über oder schwindelig?
Ich habe heute Nacht etwas wie Schüttelfrost gehabt und habe etwas Fieber.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, 38,6.
38,6.
Im Mund.
Haben Sie sich erbrochen?
Nein, aber ich habe keinen großen Appetit.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen wenig gegessen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist normal, konstant.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang, Verstöpfe oder Durchfall?
Ja, seit 3 Tagen habe ich Beschwerden beim Stuhlgang.
Es tut weh, wenn ich etwas pressen muss.
Der Stuhl ist relativ dünn.
Er ist nicht dick, sondern ein kleiner Stuhlgang.
Haben Sie beim Stuhlgang Schmerzen?
Ja, etwas.
Aber im Baus?
Haben Sie beim Stuhl Farbeveränderung oder etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Dunkel Verwärmung?
Sie meinen so etwas wie Blut?
Ja.
Vielleicht etwas mehr Schleim in letzter Zeit, aber nicht viel.
Kein Blut.
Frau Müller, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, sonst geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Ist Ihre Monatpolitur regelmäßig?
Ja, ich war vor 3 Wochen bei einer gönnekologischen Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Da war alles in Ordnung.
Okay, verstanden.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben keinen Appetit.
Okay.
Jetzt frage ich etwas zu allgemeinen Fragen,
ob Sie Ihre Krankheit vorgesehen haben.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte,
wie z.B. Zuckerkrankheit, Herzkrankheit, oder etwas anderes?
Nein, ich bin als Kind mal operiert worden am Blendarm
und hatte mal einen Bruch am Unterarm.
Beim Sport, da war ich 20 Jahre alt,
der wurde operiert mit einer Platte.
Aber so habe ich keine weiteren Erkrankungen.
Was war genau diese Operation?
Am Unterarm.
Der Arm wurde eine Platte eingesetzt,
weil der Bruch war etwas verschoben.
Okay.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Blindarm-Operation.
Sonst keine Operationen.
Blindarm-Operation ist wegen der Opandesitis?
Ja, da war ich, glaube ich, 10 Jahre alt.
Platte-Operation ist im 20. Jahrhundert.
Da war ich 20 Jahre alt, also jetzt vor 30 Jahren war das.
Okay, verstanden.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen oder Krankheiten?
Nein, ich nehme auch keine Dokumente.
Hatten Sie in letzter Zeit einen Unfall?
Nein, okay.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen
oder eine langen Reise gemacht?
Nein.
Jetzt bei Corona war ich, bin ich nicht verreist,
ausländerweise nur in Deutschland.
Frau Müller, haben Sie jetzt zurzeit
ein Problem mit der Corona-Operation?
Nein, ich nehme keine Dokumente.
Ich nehme keine Dokumente.
Haben Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, ich nehme keine Dokumente.
Haben Sie eine Alergie?
Nein, keine Dokumente.
Was ist der Problem?
Nein, gegen Medikament oder Lebensmittel, manchmal etwas, vielleicht Hausstauballägie,
aber ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Ich habe das noch nicht testen lassen. Wenn dann ist es aber auch
nicht sehr schlimm, nicht sehr ausgeprägt. Okay, haben Sie Unfallerechtigkeit?
Nein, eigentlich alles essen. Okay.
Rauhrungsee, Frau Müller? Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Trinkungsee, Alkohol? Ja, aber unregelmäßig, vielleicht mal bei einer Feier oder am Wochenende mal
ein Glas Wein, aber das ist nicht immer, nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, geregent nicht kann man sagen. Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich, das ist eine
Loutinefrage, die ich frage muss. Konsumieren Sie Alkohol oder haben Sie dabei Erfahrung?
Mit Alkohol oder mit Drogen?
Konsumieren Sie Drogen? Nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau Müller, gibt es irgendwelche chronische oder wichtige Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Nein, in der Familie. Also ich habe zwei Kinder, die sind 21 und 18 Jahre alt, aber die sind gesund.
Und meine Eltern, mein Vater ist 84 Jahre alt und hat Alterszucker.
Bei Mutter, habe ich sie gesehen. Nee, der Vater. Alterszucker und Bluthochdruck.
Und die Mutter, die ist 82 Jahre alt, die hat Berlingrömer.
Berlingrömer, meine Mutter. Okay, verstanden.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater? Was haben Sie gesagt? Vater, mein Vater ist 84.
Und Ihr Kinder 21? 21 Jahre und 18 Jahre.
18 Jahre? Okay, Sie sind gesund.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet? Ja.
Mit mir leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie, oder?
Ich lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen. Aber die Kinder wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Sie sind schon irgendwo anders.
Okay, was machen Sie bei der Familie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin Krankenschwester.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, die Arbeit ist sehr anstrengend, aber die Arbeit ist auch sehr schön.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt bei Corona ist es besonders anstrengend, aber es geht.
Ich fühle mich da trotzdem wohl.
Okay, Frau Müller, sind Sie vollgeimpft gegen Kinderkrankheit oder gegen Corona?
Ich habe sogar schon die zweite Booster-Impfung.
Auch gegen Kinderkrankheit? Sind Sie geimpft?
Ja, die normalen Impfungen, auch habe ich alles gemacht.
Difterie, Tetanus, Keuchus, Kind, Masern, Mund, Röteln, Polio.
Das habe ich alles. Die Impfungen, glaube ich, sind ganz komplett. Hepatitis.
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau Müller, ich habe auch einige Fragen.
Straden, Dschmerzen, wohin auch in andere Körpersregionen, z.B. Oberschenkel oder Rücken?
Nein, in den Unterbauch links.
Okay, haben Sie bei Ihnen Blesse oder Antrieblöse gerechnet?
Ich fühle mich manchmal müde, wenn die Arbeit sehr anstrengend war.
Dann fühle ich mich müde und erschöpft, aber das ist nicht jeden Tag so.
Es gibt manche Tage, da fühle ich mich müde, dann kann ich aber auch gut schlafen.
Okay, keine Gewichtsabnahme in letzter Zeit, haben Sie schon gesagt?
Nein.
Okay, ich habe alles gefragt, was ich brauchen möchte.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, etwas sein.
Was kann es denn sein?
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher mit dem Bauchschmerz.
Was denken Sie?
Frau Müller, jetzt ist es sehr schwer, eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und dann einige Labore untersuchen.
Okay.
Nach der Untersuchung werden wir wieder sprechen.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Machen Sie wieder fünf Minuten?
Ja, es wäre besser.
Ich kann etwas fragen.
Haben Sie Probleme, das Wasser zu halten, zum Beispiel beim Nissen,
oder müssen Sie zum Beispiel sofort auf die Toilette gehen,
werden Sie Handrang verspüren?
Nein, ich kann das Wasser gut halten.
Also ich habe auch da bisher keine Probleme mit der Blase oder so.
War bisher nichts Auffälliges.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich kann ganz gut schlafen.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Ein- oder Ausatmen?
Nein, ich treibe Sport, ich jogge zweimal in der Woche, 10 km.
Das fällt mir nicht schwer.
Leiden Sie unter residivierenden Harman-Infektion?
Nein, ich habe eigentlich noch nie eine Blasenentzündung gehabt.
Ich habe noch nie einen Tag mit der Strecke,
wie viel müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Können Sie das nochmal wiederholen?
Müssen Sie häufig auf die Toilette gehen?
Nein, normalerweise einmal am Tag.
Okay.
Und andere Fragen, ich möchte andere Fragen.
Diese Patienten, Krankenschwester, meine Kollegen sind ich denke,
wenn unsere Patient eine Krankenschwester ist,
wie sollen wir reagieren?
Eine Empathie zeigen müssen wir, eine Empathie zeigen oder andere?
Ich denke, das macht keinen Unterschied, ob ich jetzt eine Krankenschwester bin
oder ob ich eine Verkäuferin bin oder eine Polizistin bin
oder eine Sekretärin bin.
Ich denke, man soll immer eine gewisse Empathie zeigen gegenüber jedem Patienten
und da würde ich jetzt keinen Unterschied machen.
Ob es jetzt eine Krankenschwester ist oder ein Kollege eventuell ist,
muss man vorsichtig sein, dass man sich nicht ganz besonders verhält.
Und dann erstmal versuchen, eine möglichst objektive Anamnese zu erheben.
Okay, machen wir fünf Minuten?
Genau.
Ich brauche zwei, drei Minuten.
Okay, machen wir.
Alles gut.
Kommt wieder.
Ich fange an.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberast.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Okay, ja.
Frau Susanne Müller ist 50-jähriger Patientin,
die sich bei uns seit drei Tagen bestehende Bauchschmerzen
und Druckgefühl vorgestellt hat.
Die Schmerzen sind perumbikial angefangen,
aber dann im Linken Unterbauch gewandert.
Die Patienten beschreiben Schmerzen krampfartig
und belertet die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala
bei sechs, acht von zehn.
Sie hat schon 50,
Sie hat schon früher 50 verdient,
aber die Schmerzen sind drei Tage in Schlima geworden.
Laut der Patientin ist die Schmierze,
relativ dünne und schleimig.
Und wie Goethe Tivanamese sagte,
Fibre 38,8 Grad,
Schütterfrust und Interpretenz.
Bei der Patientin ist keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt,
aber sie hat in der Kindheit mit zehn Jahren
eine beliebte Operation.
Eine Appendectomy.
Eine Appendectomy bekannt.
Wegen der Perforierte Appendicitis.
Oder in Folge eine Perforierte Appendicitis bekannt.
Und auch in Folge Sport Traumas.
Im 20. Lebensjahr,
eine Unterfraktur mit den Piloten behandelt.
Die Patientin nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Und sie sind vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten
und gegen Corona.
Kinderkrankheiten?
Kinderkrankheiten und gegen Corona.
Auch mit Buster.
Bei der Patientin ist eine der Motorfolge Test-Elergie ist bekannt,
aber sie hat gesagt, dass sie nicht so schlimm ist.
Und die Patientin ist nicht geopert.
Und Trink, Einglas, Wein,
und nicht so unterschiedlich,
die
Leider Mutter ist Gelek, Rheuma oder Fachbegriff?
Gelek, Rheuma, Polyatrose, Polyatritis.
Polyatis.
Wie ist die Patientin möglich?
Hat die Patientin Geschwister?
Leider habe ich nicht gefragt.
Okay.
Die Patientin verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder, die gesund sind.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Mann.
Sie ist Krankenschwestern vom Beruf.
Sie hat Stress bei der Arbeit, aber sie beisst ihre Arbeit sehr schön.
Alles sehr schön.
Und ihre Monatskulutung ist regelmäßig.
Die letzte Periode war vor drei Wochen.
Ja, okay.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Meine Verdachtstiagnose.
Ich bin ja nichts, aber meine Verdachtstiagnose ist Divertikulitis.
Divertikulitis?
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Ja, kann man vom Urlaub.
Ja.
Linker Unterbau?
Herz.
Differenzialdiagnostisch? Was kommt in Betracht?
Ja, weiß die Differenzialdiagnose kommen.
Die Differenzialdiagnostisch ist aus einer Polyp.
Sie ist aus einer Polyp.
Ja.
Gynäkologisch?
Es ist unwahrscheinlich, weil die Patientin vor drei Wochen
bei der Gynäkologin war.
Und sie hat gesagt, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Ja, okay, aber es könnte theoretisch auch eine Art,
ja, ja, genau.
Ja, also differenzial diagnostisch muss man da zumindest noch mal dran denken.
Kolitis, Sigma-Karzinom, Kolonkarzinom.
Am ehesten ist vielleicht in Anbetracht des Alters,
die Patientin klagt, dass sie vor einiger Zeit wohl schon einmal diese Bauchschmerzen hat, glaube ich,
haben sie gesagt, muss man wahrscheinlich an eine Sigma-Divertik-Kolitis denken,
als Arbeitsdiagnose.
Und was wollen Sie jetzt untersuchen?
Ja, genau.
Ich wurde natürlich zuerst körperlich untersuchen, durchführen.
Mit Schwerpunktunterbau.
Ich wurde Druckschmerz und Loslossschmerzen überprüfen.
Und Vitalizahim übermesst.
Temperatur, klinische Untersuchung, körperliche Untersuchung, Labor mit Entzündungsparametern.
Ja.
Da warten wir eventuell für ein Erzündungsparameter im Blut,
wenn jetzt eine Kolitis da ist.
Ich erwarte Alp-Lukustusen und C-Alp-Alp-Hung und B-SG-Alp-Hung.
Ja.
Ich denke mir, das ist erst mal eine gute Hypotese.
Arbeitsdiagnose, Patienten muss nicht umbleiben.
Parenterale Ernährung, damit der Darm entlastet wird.
Eventuell gegebenenfalls wir vielleicht operieren müssen,
aber bei einer Sigma-Divertik-Kolitis macht man das in der Regel ja nicht,
sondern versucht, erst mal konservativ zu behandeln.
Wann würden Sie eine Koloskopie vorschlagen?
Ja, aber vor der Koloskopie würde ich Optimätsunografie durchführen.
Und nach der Sonografie ist eine Koloskopie, kann hilfreich sein.
Kann hilfreich sein, wenn wir den Eindruck haben, es ist eine Sigma-Divertikolitis.
Macht man ja oft erst eine Koloskopie dann im Intervall, etwas später.
Wenn wir allerdings den Verdacht haben auf einen tumorösen Prozess,
dann muss man natürlich eine Koloskopie zügig vorbereiten anschließen.
Ja, ich denke, ich bin damit zufrieden, wie Sie mir das vorgestellt haben. Danke.
Denken Sie bitte jetzt noch mal dran, Sie haben das sehr gut, finde ich, gemacht,
sehr gut systematisiert, dass Sie häufig mich anschauen, die Patientin anschauen
und nicht zu oft auf Ihr Papier schauen.
Aber es ging, es war okay, aber nicht zu oft, nicht immer dann zu oft runterschauen,
sondern versuchen Sie möglichst viel Blickkontakt zu haben.
Und Sie haben das von der Sprache her, finde ich, sehr gut gemacht.
Daran denken bei der Familienanamnese, dass Sie auch nach Geschwistern fragen.
Deswegen habe ich extra nochmal gefragt, gibt es Geschwister, weil Sie haben Geschwister vergessen.
Ja, ich habe das von meinen Eltern, das sind die Elternvererkrankungen
und dann auch sicher noch im Rahmen der Familienanamnese fragen, haben Sie Geschwister.
Das ist vielleicht noch um das Ganze komplett zu machen.
Okay. Aber ansonsten, glaube ich, können Sie gut in eine Prüfung geben?
Wann haben Sie denn Prüfung?
Am 6. 20. Februar.
Ja.
Nach 10 Tagen.
Ja, aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl.
Wenn Sie schön ruhig bleiben und Ihre Sätze ruhig formulieren,
dann glaube ich, es wird eine gute Prüfung.
Danke schön. Kann ich eine Frage stellen? Herr Weiko, Sie haben Arbeitsdiagnose gesagt.
Was bedeutet Arbeitsdiagnose?
Man kann sagen, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose.
Das finde ich immer ganz wichtig. Also, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Da würde ich als Erstes sagen, ich habe den Verdacht auf eine Diverticulitis,
Differenzialdiagnostisch, und das haben Sie ja dann gesagt,
Colitis ulcerosa, Sigma-Carsinom, so etwas.
Und wie gesagt, als Ergänzung eventuell noch Atnexitis.
Das reicht da. Drei Differenzialdiagnosen finde ich reichenderfällig aus.
Es ist kein Hinweis dafür, dass das eine urologische Erkrankung ist
von der klinischen Symptomatik her.
Das ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, das Wort Arbeitsdiagnose sage ich auch gerne,
das ist so meine Basis von, wo ich jetzt ausgehe in der Diagnostik,
ohne dass man sich zu sehr eingrenzt und immer nur sagt,
das ist eine Sigma-Diverticulitis und rechts und links vielleicht eine andere Diagnose übersieht.
Aber als Erstes würde ich vielleicht mal Richtung Sigma-Diverticulitis denken.
Ja.
Vielen Dank.